[Music]
thanks for joining us and this is a
session on how BuzzFeed built a great
user experience using bigquery and
looker
I'm Rami Hassan and I'm a customer
engineer for the Google cloud team
supporting BuzzFeed and coming up
shortly will be nick hardy who's a
senior business analyst over at BuzzFeed
who's gonna kind of go through the story
of who BuzzFeed is not that any of you
don't know who they are
but kind of take you through their
journey of heading on to bigquery all
the kind of hiccups that they went
through the problems they were trying to
solve where they are today and kind of
where they want to go in the future as
well and not forgetting obviously what
they're using and taking advantage of
with looker
so we'll have a Q&A session at the end
so please try to save any of your
questions for that and with that I'll
hand it over to Nick data to our users
and why that's so important DOS is an
organization so before I do that I
wanted to sort of set the stage and talk
about our work I'm sure a lot of you
guys are familiar with our content but I
think a lot of people don't realize sort
of the breadth of the type of work that
we're doing and also all the platforms
that it lives on and I think that that's
really important for context for the way
we think about our data problems so of
course we kind of have our classic
BuzzFeed content like the dress I'm sure
you guys are all team blue black or
white and gold we talk about that after
but we also have our news content which
actually recently moved on to its own
domain so that came with it so instead
of fun challenges we have our newly
launched lifestyle vertical which is
called as is and then we also have a
bunch of video content which lives on
eboshit four platforms so of course
taystee quite big on Facebook a lot of
people actually don't realize that this
is BuzzFeed but it is and then also
things like worth it which live on
YouTube so that's actually kind of a
great sort of segue into the way that we
think about our data and some of the
problems that we have to solve so I'm
just gonna give you guys some quick
stats so you can understand sort of the
scale the problem that we're trying to
solve so we get about nine billion
monthly content views that's coming
from all of our different platforms
that's buzzfeed.com that's our apps it's
Facebook its youtube its Instagram and
snapchat about 200 million monthly
unique visitors to BuzzFeed com
specifically tens of thousands of assets
so we kind of actually have a unique
problem sort of taking all the
statistics and attaching them to
metadata specifically for content that's
living on multiple platforms and data
from at least 20 platforms now because
we're a Content company content
analytics are kind of at the center of
everything we do and we actually have
really placed a huge emphasis on making
that the role not just of our data
science and analytics team but actually
everybody in the company and especially
the people who are making stuff so this
is actually a slide that I stole from
our CEO Jonah who has a really great
philosophy from sort of the way that he
thinks about these things we like to
think about these things in terms of
sort of the feedback loops that we're
creating right so people who are making
stuff or at the center of everything
that we're doing but they're also
pushing this content out to all
different places to our site to our apps
to all these different distributed
platforms and what we sort of get back
in return is data and learnings and also
for lucky sometimes some money but what
that also means that our reality is that
we're left sort of grappling with data
coming in from all of these different
platforms and this is actually just a
sampling of the different things that
we're working with but as you can
imagine we sort of are stuck with his
problem things coming in at different
formats some stuff that's time-series
some stuff is aggregate so that's sort
of kind of the heart of what we're
trying to solve so great segue to my
problem as a data team how do we
consolidate all of this data in one
place make it easy for hundreds of users
with varying skill sets to understand so
of course we have data scientists
analysts engineers working looking at
the stuff we also have content creators
we also have people on our business team
so we have a really broad spectrum in
terms of people's expertise and comfort
with data which actually creates a sort
of unique problem of its own in terms of
the way that we want to display this
stuff to users and how easy we need to
make it for them to understand and then
of course how do we accomplish these
first two goals without putting an
enormous and continual burden on our
data and engineering teams right so
that's actually gonna be a really
central piece of what I talk about today
so how do we actually do it I'm gonna
say something today that will probably
make it easier said than done and I
really want to emphasize before I say
any of those that this was a big process
for us and I took
really took a village in terms of the
number of number people the number of
teams I worked on and I actually have a
number of my great teammates sitting
here in the fourth row here didn't come
talk to us after so the first piece of
this was building a strong foundation
and again I'm gonna oversimplify a
little bit here but what it really came
down to for us was one critical piece
and that was really just getting
everything in the same place so for us
that was bigquery obviously that's me
presenting a grossly oversimplified
version of what it took to get there so
I can talk a little bit about the
infrastructure that we use to do that
and if you guys have more specific
questions about this we can cover it
more in Q&A or you can come find us
after and I'd be happy to sort of chat
through it but basically what we what we
ultimately landed on was that in order
for this to work in order for us to
accomplish our goals we needed to funnel
everything through the same pipeline and
land it in the same place now we're very
fortunate at BuzzFeed that one of our
VPS of engineering was one of the people
who co-authored nsq so we had a great
sort of data pipeline is sit on top of
so everything runs through there and it
lands in GCS and then ultimately in
bigquery which is sort of what we can
use to service it back up to all of our
users you'll see some internal tools
that we've built in here as well I'll
talk a little bit about those but not
too much and again if you have questions
just come find us after we happy to chat
about it so once you're gonna have that
foundation in place you have all your
data in bigquery now you have the real
task ahead of you of sort of building
the home that your users are gonna live
in and I like to think about this in
terms of building with bricks and that
straw because you're trying to build
something that's gonna last for the long
haul so when we thought about this we
sort of knew that we had two big groups
that we were building for one was going
to be the data team and then the other
was going to be the users so I'm gonna
sort of talk about those in two steps to
talk about the data team first and then
the user second so the first thing we
knew was going to be super super
critical for our data team in particular
to accomplish its goals was going to be
finding a way to minimize the friction
it took to get new data in particular in
the warehouse this was something that
was a huge problem for us as our team as
our company went from being a company
that made lists posts that lived on a
website to suddenly being a company that
was publishing across a bunch of
different platforms and had content
living in all different places every
time we needed to upload new data before
we had bigquery it was this very very
laborious
to ask for us where we were writing new
table schemas writing migrations
bothering people for backfill and that
was something that just didn't work so
when we set out into our adventure of
moving everything over into bigquery
that was one of the things that was most
important to us during the build-out so
there were a couple of things that we we
did in terms of the way that we
architected the system that sort of
proven to be super super important for
us and allowed us to move much more
quickly than we were in the past so the
first one is that all of our pipeline
data just go straight into GCS seems
like kind of a simple face value thing
but it's actually super important
because what that means is that we don't
have to do any work as a data team to
get stuff into the place that it needs
to be for us to get it into bigquery if
it passes through the pipeline it's
there the second one was that all it
required for us to actually import data
is writing a JSON schema so previously
like I said we had to write these
migrations we had to bother people for
backfill now all of that's built in all
you do is write a config for what you
want your table to look like you deploy
that your data is there you can deploy
those tables at any time with a review
from your teammate you're not blocked by
the data engineering team and you get
your backfill for free which is
something that was super super crucial
for us all you do is write in a start
date as long as the log files are there
you'll get that data back so whatever
start date you set so this has been huge
for us and it's totally changed the way
that we think about our workflow and
actually getting the data that we needed
into our system so that we can service
it to our end users so once we've done
that with a couple of other things that
were super important and the biggest one
of these was actually giving analysts
and data scientists the tools they need
to build for less technical users so we
had taken a philosophy in the past where
we had actually built a lot of stuff
in-house and when we were just a
publisher that made list content that
lived on the website like I said earlier
that actually served us really well
because we had something that was custom
built to our needs but it didn't scale
very well as soon as we sort of started
publishing on all these other platforms
it became a really really big burden for
us to find a way to incorporate that new
stuff into dashboards because we were
suddenly relying on our engineering team
to help us sort of do the whole process
of how do we redesign this how do we do
this whole thing so we knew we needed a
better system that would allow us to
iterate more quickly I was like I said
this is sort of the core of the way that
we think about everything we do we
really want to be able to power that
feedback loop for our con
creators so what we ultimately landed on
was that we needed to use a third-party
solution and the one that we picked was
looker I'm sure some of you guys are
familiar with this with looker and I'm
gonna talk a little bit more about why
it works for us and why I might work for
you
so why did we choose looker like I said
one of the biggest things that we found
was gonna be huge for us was the minimal
damn overhead you do need to have a
little bit of maintenance at the initial
setup but once that's sort of in place
your data team can actually do a lot of
a heavy lifting because looker manages a
lot of the front end and you're really
just sort of managing the data modelling
piece which is something that most dated
teams can do on their own
the second thing that works really
really well for us and keep in mind
those sort of varying skill sets that I
mentioned earlier when I'm talking about
this is that it can support both a
general and a specific use case so what
does that actually mean
looker actually has created different
versions of their experience for people
who have different levels of comfort
working with data so they call this
Explorer versus dashboards they're you
know sort of different ways that you can
think about what that actually mean this
example that you're seeing here is a
dashboard so this is a very curated
experience that's someone who's a little
less comfortable working with the raw
data might see this is actually a real
dashboard that we have this is showing
you completions and results for a
specific quiz so if you're someone who's
writing quizzes for BuzzFeed comm you
want to come in you want to see what
results people were getting what they're
choosing for different questions we
actually are able to serve this alright
to you and a very curated looker
experience where all you have to do is
put in a URL so we're taking a lot of
the burden off of the end user in terms
of having to understand how that data is
structured where it comes from how to
pull it how to initial a tit they get
the answers that they need super quickly
but we can also support a much more
specific use case for someone like an
analyst maybe someone on our finance
team so liquor calls this Explorer the
way that it looks is it's essentially a
big pivot table that sits right on top
of your data warehouse you have someone
on your on your more technical data team
that comes in and sort of sets with the
modeling layer which will define the
dimensions and the measures and sort of
how those things are aggregated it's all
sequel based to a language called look
ml that's kind of a weird hybrid between
llamo and sequel but it's pretty easy to
work with and it allows us to sort of
support these more specific use cases so
if let's say our finance team wants to
come in here and cut stuff up by months
and countries and all sorts of different
things that most users don't need they
have access to do that stuff right here
in the tool and this is actually the
Explorer that undergirds this dashboard
I just showed you guys so you can see
how does the two things sort of connect
to each other um there were a couple of
other things that we found worked really
well for us when we were looking at
looker and a bunch of other tools one of
the other key ones is that it has tons
of off-the-shelf access controls so this
was important for us for a couple of
reasons first of all we have users that
are working across these different
platforms
some people might work on say Facebook
and YouTube but you might have some
people who work on just snapchat or just
Instagram and one of the things that we
found early on is that it was very
confusing and overwhelming for them to
like be able to see just everything if
that's not what they needed so this
allowed us to sort of partition off the
experience and make it a little bit more
digestible by only showing people the
things that they wanted to see here they
needed to see similarly you could
imagine this become very useful if you
have sensitive data in your instance so
the ways that a lot of other people uses
is that if they have to say revenue data
or finance data that they only want
specific teams to be able to see you can
kind of use it in the same way we've
done that a little bit but it's
something that's sort of a left less
important for the way that we think
about how this data is surface we really
like to democratize and make most things
available to most people another thing
that's great is that it's actually
version control so it's connected
directly to get this is super helpful
for the modeling layer it's also
extremely helpful when something breaks
and you're trying to figure out what
happened you can actually like chase it
back to a specific commit this has also
been really helpful because we're using
we're relying pretty heavily on a
functionality that looker has it's
called PD T's persistent derived tables
so what it allows you to do is to kind
of create your own on-the-fly
aggregations that run on a schedule and
are cached so if you say have hourly
data that you want to roll up daily or
monthly you can actually do this right
and looker it's all version control you
can sort of see how those aggregations
are working how they're changing
something that's worked really well for
us so much so that we're actually
starting to steal it into one of our own
features which I'll talk about in a
little bit and then it's also been a
great prototyping ground so we still
have our home home built tools we still
rely on those a bunch sort of as like
kind of the front page for the way that
a lot of people experience data with
Booker being kind of the deeper use case
that they have
so this has been a great place for us to
sort of test out new new data
experiences that we want to make
available to people and potentially
integrate into our existing tools which
is actually something you can see we've
done with that same quiz data that I
showed you so now we have this tool
called - bird this was the old dashboard
that I showed you about that was created
originally just to show post performance
so we've now gone and taken that more
granular quiz performance data and just
incorporated it directly into the
dashboard experience for all our quizzes
this is something that users really like
it reduces the friction they can kind of
see everything they want in one place
and getting data like that
into this experience previously would
have been something that would have
required a lot more work a lot more
effort a lot more dev hours so it's a
way that we've sort of been able to
reduce the lead time on some of these
things and also test much more quickly
right I think we would have been much
more hesitant to build something like
that knowing that it would have required
so much to have worked previously and
now we were able to kind of just plop it
right in there so I've talked a lot
about our data team and I want to talk a
little bit about the way that we think
about building for our non-technical
users because these are really the
people that are most important and
they're on the front lines so this boils
down to sort of four things that we
found in our experience and the many
iterations of building within looker the
first one and this is actually a huge
reason that we chose bigquery is that
people want answers really quickly we
sort of were the architects of our own
demise in the sense that we had been
very thoughtful about the way that we
had engineered a lot of our home built
tools so people were used to things
loading really really quickly so when we
suddenly put them in an environment
where they were hitting a data warehouse
rather than say Castlevania or a Redis
cache they were like why is this taking
so long to load I'm used to like two
seconds and suddenly I'm waiting two
minutes for things so bigquery was a way
for us to alleviate a lot of those
problems create an experience that was
much faster and much more attune to what
people were used to particularly you
know when you consider that a lot of
these people are non-technical and their
eyes kind of glaze over when you start
explaining it and then the reason that
the thing is slow is not because they
did something wrong or you did something
wrong but just because the warehouse is
taking a long time or maybe has a big
query backlog right now so that's a
place where bigquery has helped
a lot another thing we found and I sort
of alluded to this earlier is that less
is more when we first started working
with liquor we sort of were like oh my
god we can suddenly open up the whole
warehouse to everybody this is so great
and that actually was really bad because
people got into this experience and they
were like I don't know what any of this
stuff means why are there like six
different view metrics like I don't
understand the difference between a time
series like why does this number not
change at all when I add dates so we've
really sort of reeled back a lot of that
stuff tried to simplify really try to
show people sort of the bare minimum of
what they need is a starting point and
then scale up from there rather than
starting off by kind of opening up the
floodgates to that same point clearly
labeled and described fields are
everything we made a huge mistake
early on of relying on less technical
users to understand oh this is an
aggregate this is not an aggregate it
just was a big mistake and we actually
lost a lot of trust that it took us a
little while to build back so this is
something that I like can't emphasize
highly enough and as we sort of work
through a lot of these challenges we've
actually imposed a very strict Scott
style guide on our technical users that
is requiring them to do a lot of these
things because of how important we found
it to be and then the last piece sort of
in tune of what I show you guys on the
last slide we've really tried not to
fight existing workflows if we don't
have to
so if users already have a tool that
they're used to going to if there's a
way for you to sort of integrate the
different things you're doing together
that's something that we found works
super super well so now that I sort of
watch you guys through all this where
has it actually gotten us where are we
today
so this is our usage as of a couple of
weeks ago so we have hundreds of
terabytes of data across 300 plus tables
accessible to our analysts and our users
via bigquery I've been told that we
actually are just starting to cross into
into petabytes territory now with some
of the new stuff that we've been
importing we're running over a hundred
thousand queries a day so bear in mind
I've talked a lot about looker and
supporting our non-technical users but
look bigquery is also supporting all of
our different technical use cases so on
machine learning models all of the sort
of regularly scheduled jobs so you can
see looker actually is only about five
to ten percent of our total
workflow in a day but we're really
relying on bigquery super heavily for
all of our data needs and then one of
the things that we're actually super
proud of is that we have more than half
of our 1,500 employees using a looker
each month which I think really speaks
to what we've been able to accomplish
here especially when you consider the
fact that most of those users are people
that are not used to interacting with
the BI tool and are usually content
creators writers editors that sort of
thing so a little bit in terms of what's
next for us we're starting to experiment
with a new tool that you guys are gonna
hear more about today and tomorrow we
were one of the early access partners
for bigquery machine learning this is
something that we're really excited
about because it allows us to really
open up machine learning to a lot more
of our analysts whereas previously there
were a much more stringent technical
requirements in terms of who can do that
type of work this is also something
that's been developed in partnership
with looker which is really cool for us
because it allows us to sort of just
plug in and see sort of some things like
our model performance statistics right
in the looker experience that we're used
to using to that end we're actually
continuing to expand pretty heavily on
our existing recommendation systems so
this is something that actually powers a
lot of what you see on the BuzzFeed site
and even what you see on our Facebook
pages it's all happening behind the
scenes but it's stuff that you might not
realize is there so it's the way that we
optimize our feeds this is the way that
we're recommending content to our social
media editors to post on our different
Facebook pages we have about 140 of
those so you can imagine that that gets
to be a pretty complicated problem for
them so this is a place where we're
investing super heavily and and our use
of GCP and and bigquery has allowed us
to really reduce a lot of the friction
there and move much more quickly
and then we're also working on our own
materialized view solution so we
actually are just finished our version 1
launch of this and are starting to
launch on version 2 so this is the
solution that's akin to lookers
persistent derived table solution so we
really liked the idea of being able to
have sort of cache
aggregation x' that we could access but
what we didn't like was having that
locked specifically into looker because
we were running into these scenarios
where say a data scientist was working
on a model and wanted to access our
denormalized Facebook statistics and
that was only in looker and suddenly
you're hitting the looker API and then
having to do all this additional
manipulation so what we decided to do
was actually build our own solution for
this and our date engineering team who
again is sitting right there has been so
great through this process and I
personally is it as a big user of this
could not be more thrilled with the way
that it's it's turned out but this is
something that we think is going to be
really crucial for us in terms of
offering our game in terms of our data
government governance having really
consistent ways that we think about
cleaning up our data aggregating our
data so this is actually a bit of the
work that I'm sort of the most excited
about right now
[Music]